so tonight's the night that really
should make a difference in America in
the race for the White House earlier I
spoke to the two-time Republican
presidential candidate and former
congressman Ron Paul his son rant has
also been running for the Republican
nomination I began by asking him why
he's described Donald Trump as being
worse than the party's establishment
candidates because he's very very smart
and he is very efficient and he's tapped
into the problems of this country but I
don't like any of his solution so
therefore I see him worse in a perverse
sense because of his his effectiveness I
think he will be able to do what he
wants to do and from a libertarian view
point he wants to be a boss and we don't
like the idea of people being very
effective in telling other people what
to do we'd like to see a government
where there was less of that
authoritarianism so in that sense I
think he would be worse than the rest
the others are a little bit a little bit
more inept in what they're doing so they
would be less successful in running an
authoritarian type government I mean he
is proposing the biggest tax cut like
you he opposed the Iraq war so it would
seem on some fairly major issues he's
pretty close to your position well I
don't think so because you know he was
asked about his statement when the war
broke out there ya go over there and
finish it off Bush to Bush one didn't do
is that we should get will he believe we
should go in and when he was asked about
and he says ho ho that's what I wasn't a
politician so now he's a politician so
he can change his tune I think that
there are times but there are times that
Sanders speaks better on foreign policy
but he's still not with us on not
subsidizing the military-industrial
complex and and you take you take Trump
I mean he says we go out a bill rebuild
our military we have the strongest
military the history of the world and
nobody's going to attack us and he was
he supporting all that spending we need
more money I'm going to really rebuild
our military that is not very appealing
to me when we're a totally bankrupt
station what about this idea of building
a wall with Mexico and getting the
Mexicans to pay for it I think it's
crazy and I think walls have been more
built to keep people in and to keep
people out so walls aren't a very
appealing the fact that there's problems
on immigration you should solve the
problems and I our program is a
subsidized immigration that people can
come if they break the law they get to
be citizens and they qualify for welfare
and you know this sort of thing so if
you eliminate that but if you would also
take into consideration at our welfare
state contributes to the unemployment
because people people who are getting
full welfare benefits they don't
increase their benefits if they take a
job if it's low paying so the incentives
there aren't to work and and people
don't like immigrants because it's an
embarrassment to our own policies
because a lot of our own citizens won't
work so I don't I think I don't think
you can solve that problem with a fence
you saw that problem by improving one's
own country having a freer market if you
have a free and prosperous market
there's always a shortage of Labor
you've cold Donald Trump authoritarian
some people in Europe are liking him to
Mussolini particularly after that quote
do you think that's fair oh you know I
am NOT a student of Mussolini I know
what he stood for and they'd be similar
in one way they're authoritarians but
almost everybody in Washington is
authoritarian to some degree I guess
they endorsed these viewpoints but I
wouldn't be you know I say a lot of
negative things about Trump but I try to
explain it in terms of his foreign
policy and also his economic policies
but I would never go out and volunteer
and say oh yeah they're right he's
Mussolini he coming you know but I can
understand people who who might say that
because you know is sort of a you know
xenophobia that he's playing on and who
knows what his personal beliefs are but
right now he knows that it's a selling
point he's pretty good at the
perceptions of what the American p
poor thinking and the American people
are very willing to blame somebody else
rather than themselves what about the
other contenders on the Republican side
menu you've mostly been a Republican in
your career or they used of the
libertarians the two senators crews from
your state says he's a tea partier and
also of course mr. Rubio from Florida do
you fancy either of those well I think
you know the original modern day tea
party was started during one of my
presidential races and it involved you
know you know libertarian ideas but
they're not libertarian the Republican
Party and the Tea Party organizations
were taken over by Republicans and most
of them are neoconservative is therefore
more War I mean Cruz thinks you should
carpet bomb everybody that says boo at
us and include and and Rubio is very
very solid in the camp of the
neoconservatives he seems to have been
the pic and the choice by the
establishment Republicans since nobody
else is you know since the others like
bush and others have faded there
supporting him so they don't offer
anything whatsoever other than deception
especially Cruz Cruz says the right
things in all but he's he's very much of
an authoritarian so who you going to
vote for today and indeed on November
the eighth well probably vote for Rand
Paul his name is still on the ballot so
I'm not going to waste my vote and vote
for somebody I think a completely off
track so I'll try to make my vote count
the best of all I'll vote and make the
point that if the conditions would have
been different in the coverage a little
bit different maybe the ideas of liberty
would have prevailed over the ideas that
we need more government than all the
Democrats and all Republicans their
answers are all with more government and
more more spending and of course from my
viewpoint that's going in the wrong
direction could you see yourself going
for Hillary Clinton or who knows perhaps
Mayor Bloomberg if he enters the race I
I don't think so i think they'd be all
in the same category because i don't
think the Republicans and Democrats you
know are much difference their tone is
different but but they're they're
essentially the same and they try to
appeal to a base like Sanders is maybe a
little bit better on foreign policy but
he still as part of the
military-industrial complex Hillary's
the same way she's very solidly in the
camp of military intervention so know
that there were no matter who wins in
this country believe me there will be no
no change in overall policy I'm
convinced